I want to jump to the story as we talk
about the love for America
from marca.com Trump supporters unveil
massive Trump or death Banner as a flag
at Yankees game take a look at this
image
1776-2024 Trump or death you know that
kind of freaks me out
it's like if Trump doesn't get elected
what are they saying are they saying
Give me liberty or give me death except
it's Trump instead of liberty no I don't
know that's the slogan of Cuba right
there are they saying that if Trump
isn't elected it will be death what is
the slogan of Cuba
your country or death that's that's the
slogan that's a Cuban slogan right there
which is why that song went viral uh
page like your country or death that's
the slogan what's like what's the the
wrecked literal translation it's Patriot
Patriot is your Homeland Homeland
homelander death wow yeah with Thomas
was it Thomas Henry Give me liberty or
give me death that's the whole like give
me exactly what I want or I'll die no no
no no no no that's not what he's saying
he's saying leave me alone or I will
fight you oh that's what's being well
Liberty the freedom to do what I want or
I will fight for that Liberty and that
means I will fight to the death for that
as opposed to give me X or die it's not
it's not give me things give me death
yeah it's it's leave me alone you have
two choices either you're going to give
me my Liberty or you're going to have to
kill me but giving Liberty is basically
leave me alone it's not give me Donald
Trump yeah give me a result it's each
day off my lawn so Liberty is a negative
right so you don't need to be given a
thing or you don't need someone else to
act on your behalf there it's not a
positive action to have Liberty right so
Give me liberty is leave me alone like
don't try to take a positive action
action against me but in Cuba for it's
like worship the Patriot worship the
Homeland or something else yeah that was
Fidel slogan that's what they came into
Cuba with was Padre Muerte so
um yeah when I saw that flag I was like
whoa that's authoritarian AF yeah man uh
you mentioned the charismatic guy that
comes in and destroys the world destroys
I feel like Obama did it and then Trump
just kept going well we all thought
about Obama was going to be our savior
right I mean like that was the big thing
I didn't I'm sure nobody at this table
did but I think so I had I felt like
that yeah I mean a lot finally we got it
yeah and it was like you know he's this
great guy he looks good on camera man
the man can dress you know and he's he
says all the right things and then you
know drops a few bombs on kids and
American citizens and you know it's it's
it's just
wow it's scary to watch it's scary to
watch and pay attention Obama is more
likely to be the charismatic like
if someone to come to me and said do you
think that the charismatic leader who
leader who leads the world to
destruction is around today I'd be like
it's possible if you came to me and said
you thought it was either Trump or Obama
but oh there's no question it's not
Trump the dude certainly has Charisma
but he also has serious issues with half
the country and a lot of people really
don't like him he he's he's not
is the famous silver silver tongue you
know world leader celebrity who was
doing awful for Trump well I don't know
if I'd say awful but Trump was like a
movie star he was a TV star like a
character actor with telling jokes you
know you're fired with a smile calling
Rosie O'Donnell fat like just a just a
charismatic even though he was sick but
you can be charismatic and cruel or
charismatic and say mean things that
upset people charismatically and that he
did that so but my point is simply if it
came down to who do you think out of the
two was more likely to be the
charismatic leader who leads the world
to Rowan it's Obama I felt like it was a
package it was it was 2008 to 2020 we
had this mess of celebrity in charge
that just made it about who who can who
can smack talk better it got hotter the
longer it went on I I think that's
probably just a a an artifact of
this is your generation but it never
happened because yeah Ronald Reagan was
a movie star but he didn't act like that
he wasn't like he did I was literally
watching a documentary earlier it's
hilarious by the way and I forgot what
it's called but it's like how my dad got
radicalized from a Democrat to far right
because of Rush Limbaugh and it was
really hilarious watching this thing
because it's it's mirror reality I mean
they got the guy from Media Matters and
this and Media Matters just posts like
insane lies all the time in conspiracy
theories and I'm like to act like you're
not in the cult and you're listening to
this guy but uh in it they're talking
about Ronald Reagan they're talking
about Richard Nixon they're talking
about the fast quick one-liners and
demagoguery and celebrity and building
Cults of personality and I'm like oh
this is really fun yeah I did with
Clinton and they play the saxophone on
Arsenio Hall or something on TV man this
documentary is about Rush Limbaugh this
is about like
you know the 2000 the 90s and 2000s this
is not about even Trump they've been
saying the same thing over and over
again they said Bush was Hitler every
Republican is Hitler it's the same game
they play every single time the
difference is social media because if
Reagan Reagan wasn't able to get his
word out without the networks going on
to like you know David Letterman or
something so that it was all Network
approved but Trump bypasses this the FCC
and goes straight to the mouth with like
Twitter and it just upended the entire
like any kind of normalcy or like things
you don't like you don't go on not
national television and call someone a
fat pig when you're the president use
that pulpit and that power and that
authority to demean someone's physical
appearance it's like what in the hell
did he just do to the essence of the
United States presidency that was a
terrible misuse of power in my opinion I
mean
I don't think that Obama was really
like I I don't think that that uh that
Trump was really significantly worse
than other presidents like they're
significantly better yeah like well when
it comes to rhetoric and stuff like that
policy people act like the rhetoric that
he that he had like like was so bad and
I agree with you about foreign policy um
but the uh I don't think that he really
was he was a little more direct in the
way that he spoke
but he wasn't
and and maybe maybe other presidents
were
they were a little more they had a
little more finesse but the thing that
people liked about Trump was that he was
just saying it like it is right like he
was an authentic guy he was bsing people
but it was not it didn't seem like it
was canned or written by a speech writer
and that people related to that he's
honest where it matters yeah he's like
we're gonna keep soldiers in Syria for
the oil we got to keep the oil we're
doing really well it's like wow yeah you
just said we're gonna sell weapons to
Saudi Arabia and we're like okay all
right and then he would be like my hair
is real and I'm the best way and you're
like okay Trump it's like he he lies a
lot but the things he lies about I don't
care about it's like people were at his
inauguration yeah exactly how many
people were there oh it's the biggest
the biggest you've ever seen is like we
know it wasn't but it's fine whatever
dude look if Donald Trump is sitting
there and he's like
he's in his room saying oh there's a
million people here right now watching
watching me sign these peace agreements
in the Middle East I'm like that's right
they're all watching and waiting for you
to sign those peace agreements please
sign them like I don't care if Trump
wants to lie about the size of
inauguration or you know the women he's
been with and all this weird stupid
nonsense cultural crap
I care that we got the Abraham Accords I
care that the economy was doing well I
care that he took tremendous efforts to
try and bring peace to parts of the
world like in North Korea
and they attack him for it and that one
deeply offends me and I love saying it
Trump crossed the military demilitarized
zone into enemy territory with no
security detail
nah you can f off anybody who's like
Trump's pointing up to dictators I'm
like oh okay yeah nice try dude that's
not gonna fly
they could have captured the President
right there on the spot and made demands
I mean they wouldn't Trump was right he
knew the move to be made but it was a
tremendous sign of good faith Trump can
tell me that his house is made of cheese
and graham crackers and sugar and candy
canes and he can look me Square in the
eyes and lie he can tell me that his
toilet is made of solid gold and I'll
say whatever you say dude keep working
on those peace agreements and I'm
satisfied
be like are you sure it's solid isn't it
just you're right you're absolutely
right I think it's played it's like
Zoolander when Zoolander looks at the
the you know the what is the institute
for kids who can't read good or whatever
and he's like how are we going to teach
them to read if they can't fit in the
building and then mugato is like he's
absolutely right like that I'm saying if
Trump wants me wants me to believe that
he had the biggest inauguration or any
other nonsense like that and he keeps
saying it I'm just gonna be like yes you
are completely correct sir and that's
all of those people at your inauguration
are cheering for you as you sign the
Abraham Accords and try and bring peace
to the Middle East
the other night like who was the best
president of my lifetime and it comes up
a lot on the show and I was like well in
red there's two ways to answer the
question one is with retrospect the
other one is at that point in my life
who was it thinking of like in this
moment who's the best it was Bill
Clinton because in the late 90s or in
the early mid 90s he was able to rally
and like make the United States seem
like the greatest country on Earth for
all of us it felt like it felt like that
it felt like we ended the Cold War and
it was finally we've solved War it felt
like it was really done and then you
find out later they're part of a
military war machine and I don't know
what happened in Bosnia and like he
was Trump's the best president of my
life and and he's just so divisive
that's why I don't pick him I I disagree
I blame the corrupt uniparty
establishment Trump was a massive
celebrity loved by everybody Barack
Obama said the American dream was to
beat Trump but Trump was an outsider who
wanted to do things like bring back
manufacturing secure our borders and the
TPP I I gotta tell you when he crushed
the TPP that's probably one of the
biggest moments where the knives came
out and then they did everything in
their power to make everybody hate Trump
I'm like everybody loves the guy he was
in home alone I'm gonna say it again
Barack Obama said the American dream is
to be Donald Trump that was the idea
before he decided to run for president
and they came after him and even the
people who there are certain celebrities
who are like oh I've been good friends
of the Trump family they're all very
very nice but Trump's a fascist and I'm
like oh get get out of here with that
look
it is not it is not hard to say that
Trump is the greatest president of my
lifetime because who am I comparing him
to Bill Clinton no please Camp George
Bush was my least favorite George so we
so in my lifetime I've had H.W bush
Clinton W bush Obama and Trump
and certainly you can compliment some of
these presidents for some things but
come on H.W bush oh please dude
what do you say we're beginning to see
the makings of a new world order and all
of that neocon garbage and Desert Storm
and everything they tried to do you get
Bill Clinton and don't get me wrong
there are some good economic stuff but
uh there's a whole lot of stuff wrong
with what bill with with Bill Clinton's
presidency and I have to say for the
most part
when it comes to those two presidents in
my lifetime
it was it was it was there was nothing
in my life that they did that mattered
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time